a gigantic task with mountains of
paperwork faced meps managing europe's
annual budget 2 300 amendments to be
voted on covering the spectrum of eu
spending energy to innovation
unemployment to ecology agriculture aid
administration
one unifying thought emerged however at
parliament's budgets committee it's just
not enough especially for an election
year
mobilized
the lion's share of the budget usually
goes to farming and support for the eu's
least wealthy members in the east the
committee voted to restore funding axed
earlier by member states
details are still being worked out but
roughly it's just shy of 135 billion
euros this year however circumstances
are different one the budget is six
percent less than last year two there's
a huge rollover of unpaid bills from
last year's budget
time says the chairman of the committee
for a fundamental change in thinking
some mep saw the glass half full though
particularly as key priorities like
innovation and youth unemployment have
been restored the big difference from
last year is a is a huge emphasis on
more money being invested into research
and development
more money being front loaded to help
youth unemployment and tackle the huge
problems we have across europe the other
big difference from 2013 is where some
six percent less than what the budget
was last year so
and in terms of austerity europe is
showing the way next steps a vote in
plenary later this month then just maybe
another round of hefty wrangling with
member states